tous les soirs depuis lundi l'avenue
mont-royal fourmille de monde
même situation sur les rues bernard dans
outremont ou ellington dans verdun les
montréalais s'étaient ennuyés de leurs
terrasses et les restaurateurs semblent
profiter de la piétonnisation de la rue
je pense que c'est positif ça nous
permet d'avoir le trip de capacités
aussi de terrasses donc ça c'est pas
négligeable en revenant du coc vite de
trois mois de fermeture
mais si je pense qu'en général les gens
répondent bien il ya quand même une
bonne circulation de piétons
notre clientèle dit quand même très
local qui se promènent déjà pas mal
appuyé à des sikhs ou en transports en
commun jusqu'à date c'est plus positif
que négatif définitivement mais on va
avoir besoin d'un petit recul pour se
donner plus de dates à la multiplication
des corridors sanitaires pour piétons
aux vélos continue quand même de semis
la grogne
d'abord chez plusieurs commerçants qui
ne sont pas restaurateur une épicerie
ces lots donc c'est très compliqué j'ai
remarqué déjà que les pagnes ont réduit
je pense les gens mentent est grande
plus ouvert où je sais pas exactement
on va voir je la fais ça va nous le dire
mais c'est sûr que je tape en faveur
puis chez bien des automobilistes
exaspérée de chercher du stationnement
ou de faire des détours
c'est l'enfer y'a pas de toit les aimer
ça c'est l'enfer oblige vous répondra
chemin sans papiers devant la
frustration la ville a dû reculer à
quelques reprises le boulevard
saint-laurent n'a pas été piétonniser
dans la petite italie d'ebola revers sur
laurier est ont récemment été retirée
côté sud pour plus de stationnement et
cette piste pour piétons et vélos
s'apprête à être enlevés sur la rue
rachel dangereusement
cet ajustement là pour répondre aux
besoins de la place qu'ont besoin et les
citoyens
la place qu'y nécessaire pour la survie
nos commerces
on le fait en continu et l'évolution de
la pandémie l'évolution d'un
comportement fait en sorte qu'on devra
attendre s'ajuster la ville répète que
tous ces aménagements sont temporaires
et que si certains restent c'est parce
que les sociétés de développement
commercial leur ont demandé